it's a shame that kawasan left larger
feeling when he left of course hurt a
little bit but you know gonna be mad
about someone who tried to go back home
let me change his number onee you guys
you didn't tell me he's like that okay
Showtime
what's up baby this is serge ibaka aka
master chef
welcome to hunger are you today I will
be cooking for Charmin thank God I don't
know what I'm expecting here today you
know I am certainly cooking up all kind
of wild stuff he hosts the talk show
called The Breakfast Club in New York so
today I would be cooking him a classic
New York bacon egg and cheese with pigs
no bacon
[Music]
about cook these pigs now it's easy you
know my sacred baby
salts and paper let's go so it's going
to take time like 20 or 15 minutes so
you seek one for me and one for my
guests next up we have two eggs I love
some eggs I'm gonna do in Congo style
learn from a foodie chef I'd love to do
this for my dad looking good so let's
keep moving
you know I'm enjoying don't smell like
you're cooking anything oh don't worry
well you can't see what here what's on
the menu today today yeah I got surprise
for you can you help me to do a foods
here I already did everything you know
you have to help me here did you wash
these apples we did oh it skin wash
these apples we clean no there's no a
restaurants wash it off you can put it
right back and cut it why am i cutting
them all fruit plate oh I thought all
the guests you yes I want to see I want
to see your skills I hope you love
basketball
I do like basketball are you exciting
about the Knicks season this season no
I'm not a next minute Knicks it trash
why would I would be at next man in New
York no I'm from me he's a Knicks fan
no nobody told you no guys nobody told
you that like you're so mad cuz I'm in
New York Knicks suck first of all I'm a
Dallas Cowboy fan grew up with Dallas
Cowboy friend become a fan my whole life
I'm saying all that to say yeah I have
suffered since the 90s with for losing
franchise in football why would I do
that in basketball right to go to the
next game great when they were in New
Jersey I've never been to a gamer but
now you want to go because since they
have kitty and who carry you know that's
gonna be light like they're not gonna do
nothing together no no I think that
they're emotional I choose need to be
higher in order for them to play
together because what we've seen over
the years from both of them is kind of
too fragile personalities like Kevin
Durant had a
account you know I mean so he can tweet
and say things about himself like that
shows a level of insecurity that I don't
think that you can have if you're trying
to lead a team on you're on your own
I just think that hymning him encourages
their emotional IQs coryza you know
people we learn from our mistakes
yes and I'm sure I'm sure Katie learn
from from what he did and then like I
say again he already want to share cheap
by will carry a 1 1 2 oh yeah but this
is this is your yeah if you come in here
weak-minded if you come in here with
thin skin if you come in here worried
about what people got to say about you
you will get eaten alive and those are
two people who absolutely care what
people think about them so the only way
that they gonna really be able to
approximate Brooklyn and if they take
the attitude of somebody from Brooklyn
and not give up I'm sure they're
prepared for they know I hope to show
they knows I'm a real big self-help guy
one of my principles is arm Olivia truth
so nobody can use your truth against you
and I call that the M&M and a team out
there you see I'm an M&M I know you've
never seen an M&M an eight-mile no Jesus
but it you know some of you that might
come from a place so much classic movies
in that and in the Congo what's a
classic you know
okay classic movie I used to watch
Scarface 20 Montana garbage garbage
because I never understood why black
people especially young black men was so
fascinated by a Cuban coming to Florida
and preferring off the drug game
especially when you had a Nino brown
like I gravitated towards Nino brown me
Jack city you see New Jack city know
what the Johnny
mantris and then people used to have
states of worship scoff feels like he
was a real person that's coffees on the
wall the post is good it was good
I never cared about it say hello to my
little friend yeah if that's what y'all
was watching in the Congo y'all had a
terrible perception and Americans I
guess that's why what do you think about
the Raptors they don't Raptors you know
what I think you are jealous of Drake
because he have a good chain no no no no
wait let me finish
Drake because you're in New York and you
don't you don't really know which team
you have to support Knicks on it's like
he have his own team and his team just
won a title this year you jealous of
that he'll be making sad rap love songs
about the Raptors this year cuz that's
how bad the Raptors about me listen I
respect the energy Drake brings to the
Toronto Raptors because when everybody
was given flack on the sidelines oh my
god that's dope you think about Jack
Nicholson with the Lakers like he
represents the new wave that just a he's
a lot more active you know you can give
the coaching or massage you know I mean
you have that pop the players like you
know young you having a good time out
there and in the culture of basketball
is something that was new
the Toronto yeah so you're they'll never
see that again
wait no no I'm stay here what is your
free agency I don't know your book Serge
Ibaka yeah a nice game I'm saying no
you're not
it's a lot that you could be doing and
you're not gonna be able to do it in
Toronto if you really be insurance well
you know Toronto you would know say that
once with the place bro it ain't LA I
mean New York if you're trying to like
branch off and entertainment Toronto
Toronto you never know when you'll leave
three agents I'm just saying you never
know can I get some tickets if I want to
come to Toronto yeah yeah all right come
support like when y'all not good when
y'all good is hard to get to if you're
gonna sit good you think so yeah
just watch hey man I have no reason to
doubt you I believe in you search okay I
mean I believe in you
cook but I believe and your ability to
play basketball you telling me y'all
gonna make ya'll still got Kyle Lowry
yeah yeah yeah younger big for the manga
so mark what's okay alright we gonna see
I'll be a maybe a seven see something
like that no we're top 5 go Boston
Indiana Milwaukee Philly hmm it's a fire
exactly you can fight alright okay so
from I got a point
next might be the seventh AC oh yeah for
the next two yeah but they don't see one
thing I believe we are top five so we
see it's a shame that Kossoff get in
left but you know it was a good solid
unit that hurt your feeling when he left
yes I'm a little bit because he was a
friend of mine mmm and then it was a
great guy great teammate great player
and then losing him
of course hurt a little bit but you know
you know what I be mad about someone who
tried to go back home did you try to get
him to stick around and y'all like have
a team eaten conversation let's go out
to eat no we already know we already
know like he wanted to go back home you
know when she got looted yeah we all
know that so he told y'all that during
the season like I mean like but after we
won the championship you know I told her
maybe in it may change his mind
try to stay one more year but yeah yeah
maybe change is not morning know ok ok
you caught a great name by the way
what's up baby
yes baby wanna do baby ooh baby yeah you
already know baby I'm here with fun guy
tomorrow
fun guy what's up baby what I do baby
yeah you already know can you try near
you let me try it
what do you mean I'm gonna say what's
that baby okay okay and then you just
you want to call me baby come on I mean
baby okay whatever makes you feel better
no it's different it's different I'm
saying maybe just to eat yeah that looks
different you know Stewie I get it magic
you know I'm so comfortable about what I
just cook for you okay
would you cool I'm sure you gonna enjoy
it what you call it's coming I don't
like that why I like mystery meat no
don't worry
speaking of meat yeah
sym she keep talking about you when you
had on a gray sweatpants her name is sim
she she worked at the radio slicer yeah
she was like what you're going to do
what would search I love that show you
be on there cooking
you're a lot of woman's man crush Monday
I guess I'm doing something good yeah
yeah yeah you know it's crazy because I
don't really know about all those things
yeah you full of this guy is so good let
me tell you how good this guy is that's
how you get all at a women by the way
just play clueless no not exactly like I
never heard that before you've dated
superstars so warm you meet let's talk
about you in those gray sweatpants it's
like I want to know whatever was that
all you of course that's a wild question
for me to be happy you didn't tell me
he's like that what you tell me you
gotta tell me all about that I thought
it's a nice guys smile is good for this
bro
that we sell boots and you just you said
those things - no I heard you talk about
a lot of mental health
what is it Porter for you um my second
book was called ship horn anxiety
playing tricks on me I put that out last
October and when you not having to go
into therapy to deal with my anxiety you
know deal with my bouts of depression
you know PTSD and I was like you know
maybe I can talk about that because
nobody ever wants to talk about their
vulnerabilities their innermost darkest
secrets but I did and one thing I
realized is going to a therapist helped
me to understand the feelings I was
feeling better so I was able to explain
and I feel like it's kind of helped
elevate the conversation about mental
health especially in the black community
oh yeah that's important welcome for you
as somebody you take somebody to go see
a therapist they're gonna say are you
crazy
yeah Prezi you know but like I'm glad
you said that because I think it's
important we all need it especially
black people we think we're doing our
self a favor favor keeping secrets
secret yeah we not you gotta share those
resources man but was it what your
Knicks and your life what's the next
about the eat your food you see that's
what I'm thinking is about to happen I
don't cook a designed food you know
different is you just don't even care
about nothing
initially day huh I know you you host
the show it's called breakfast club in
New York yes yeah so today I make you I
made you breakfast for kind of breakfast
sure open first I feel like I'm about to
be thoroughly disappointed and whatever
this is exactly this is a big snow bacon
egg sandwich with cheese
it's a classic breakfast
I don't eat pork you don't know nothing
no no poor girl when is the last time
you had poor years like that decades
they kid
that's not said you say decades oh you
bet off servant I might add that I'm not
even a pig snout okay so my God is
telling me you eat pork nobody told you
that Marcus coming up his Market Market
Street terrible researcher you you told
me he he for who told you that lie wait
there's no spoke you lie here degree
it's [ __ ] me it took me a lot of time
to cook this okay so you know either
poor get a good picture a book is a mess
now
okay come on nobody is gonna meet there
you go that's not yeah there you go
Oh Oh can you say it and had to try it -
that's a tray why this meals this is
delicacy in the Congo we eat pork and
Congo okay
yeah meat with pig snout pigs now
because huh yeah you can leave now thank
you thank you share with you proof okay
it's my turn now
you know I never had it before but one
thing about my show that's it everything
you know what you know key don't eat
pork no I'll give you that I'm not a
force here you know what you died an
offseason huh man bite into that snout
search no this is no bacon okay but so
you don't like your own cooking you know
if you don't like your own cooking
there's really no need to keep the cook
is good this is good this is there the
texture or a texture of yeah think about
all the stuff that comes out of your
nose eat anything things eat their own
okay can't be yes you're so I wouldn't
do that every time you don't like your
own car I don't need the carrot on
today's show at all we're done we got
today was good you know it's my pleasure
bro let's come back again and for next
one I need to do something you can eat
y'all go do your research next time 20
years ago you'd be doing it for so long
yeah any tips yeah man my biggest tip
I'll give me is no cootchie danger
[Music]